[TITLE MUSIC PLAYING]
ANKIT MEHTA: GCP is a set
of solutions and products
that can help you solve your
toughest business challenges.
We have external
paying customers
that run businesses on our
platforms and at massive scale.
These customers expect
developer velocity and quality.
MTHRA RAJAH: We have
thousands of engineers
at Google building this platform
at all levels of the stack.
These engineers want a
seamless developer workflow,
deterministic signals,
insights, and velocity.
ANKIT MEHTA: It is GCP
Engineering Productivity team's
role to balance these two
dimensions, between developer
velocity and quality.
For example, we
deploy GCP's console
twice a week to our users,
and with high quality.
Our goal is to establish
biweekly high-quality releases
across GCP.
MTHRA RAJAH: At
Google, we have created
a set of guiding principles
that let us have both developer
velocity and quality.
We want to share these
principles and the tools that
are available to you
so you can accelerate
at the pace your users expect.
ANKIT MEHTA: While we
at Google initially
focused on test engineering,
over a decade ago,
we started looking at
engineering productivity
holistically.
This gave us the
framework to achieve
the right balance between
developer velocity and quality.
MTHRA RAJAH: This
meant that, in addition
to doing complex
qualification across systems,
we started focusing on tooling
and infrastructure that enabled
developers themselves to
quantify their code changes
before they commit them.
ANKIT MEHTA: This, in turn,
allows us not only to catch
bugs, but prevent them, too.
This changed the way
we built, qualified,
and deployed our applications.
And we started pushing the
boundaries of both developer
velocity and quality.
MTHRA RAJAH: We balance
developer velocity and quality
at Google and on GCP
through Project Health pH.
We track key metrics across
developer productivity,
release velocity, reliability,
and most importantly, quality.
We automatically
calculate a pH level,
and aim to achieve a pH
level of 5 for all projects.
ANKIT MEHTA: Our
guiding principles
are driving test health,
avoiding performance
regressions, and high-quality,
automated releases,
all of which are anchored
in actionable metrics.
Let's zoom in on two of
these, driving test health
and avoiding
performance regressions.
For driving test health, we
aim for hermetic integration
tests, fast [INAUDIBLE],, and
elimination of test flakiness.
We have built a cloud
integration testing framework
internally that helps us
write test once, and run them
against any environment.
MTHRA RAJAH: We
enable developers
to catch performance issues
early in the development
process to avoid
performance regressions.
We have a framework
that enables developers
to create sustainable
performance automation that
can gate releases on
performance criteria.
And we aim to improve GCP's
quality and deployment
by reducing manual toil,
increasing automation,
eliminating cherry-picks,
and improving
the fidelity of the test
signal in our pre-production
environments.
ANKIT MEHTA: Let's
dive deeper into what
we are doing for the
external developer and user.
Google works closely with the
external Kubernetes and Istio
developer communities to
enable developer productivity
in open source.
Kubernetes is an
open-source system
for automating deployment,
scaling, and management
of containerized
applications, while Istio
is an open-source
service mesh that
provides traffic management,
policy enforcement,
and telemetric collection.
We are active contributors
to special interest group
SIG testing in Kubernetes.
MTHRA RAJAH: Some
of the tooling we
helped build in the open
source community includes Prow,
the continuous integration
CI system used by Kubernetes
and a lot of other projects
that use Kubernetes.
Prow is built on
top of Kubernetes.
So our CI helps test
Kubernetes on Kubernetes.
ANKIT MEHTA: Testgrid provides
a grid of test results,
making it easy to see
patterns over time,
provides fast access, and allows
interactive sorting, filtering,
grouping, and more.
It is highly configurable, and
integrated with Cloud Build.
MTHRA RAJAH: Recently, we
helped build hermetic testing
using Kubernetes and Docker.
Kind brings up a confirmed
Kubernetes cluster locally
without any external
dependencies
for testing Kubernetes
changes or integration-testing
Kubernetes applications.
Kubernetes was designed
with portability
and interoperability
in mind, and providers
want to enable
application portability.
Google, alongside
other cloud providers,
helps out with the Cloud
Native Computing Foundation's
conformance program, which
ensures certified Kubernetes
products deliver
consistency and portability.
ANKIT MEHTA: The
outside world now
uses VNs, Kubernetes containers,
scalable storage, GitHub,
and so on.
Google's software is stored
in a single shared repository.
The development landscape
is rapidly changing,
and we are evolving our
tooling and incorporating
external tooling to adapt
to this changing landscape.
Summarizing, we believe that
if you prioritize driving test
health, treat performance
as a first-class citizen,
and have automated CI/CD that
enables high-quality releases,
and measure everything--
MTHRA RAJAH: --you can
have the same developer
velocity and quality as we do.
[TITLE MUSIC PLAYING]